you said something uh that is was this a
true story where you said you you were
you were taking care of a young lady she
had a place was it in Chicago she had a
condo right and you showed up and you
were cracking jokes and some dude was
laughing under the bed is here's the
here's a a great thing about those type
of jokes yeah it's like a magician who
can't tell his the secret to her magic
that makes sense you know what I mean so
I want people to leave is that true
right or is that a real joke but then
say you got to really be clever to come
up with something like that was so good
yes thank you um talk to me about where
like like do you even like pay attention
to other standup like if Dave if Dave
Shel drops a special which he dropped on
New Year's did you check it out I didn't
check it out I know he's funny I I I
catch Dave and most comedians in bits
and pieces but I always had this
rule never watch another comic
perform because when they're good you're
going to actually take something that
they without even thinking about it
without subconscious subconscious so
when I see comedians watching me it
hurts because they don't know the rule
because I know my stuff is funny and if
you watch me I know you're going to take
something my flip it and uh um break it
down as much as possible but you got it
for me um I know you had said before
that uh you you've had some bits stolen
is yeah yeah yeah yeah I had a um um in
my days of uh younger days I used to do
a thing called things questions series
of questions and matter of fact we we've
been trying to find it I did it on the
apolla I did it everywhere and it was a
series of question I go um why a lucky
charm so magically delicious and where
is the honeycomb Hideout is it downtown
and why do old people walk so early in
the morning do they have somewhere to go
and it was like a series it got me it
got me a standing elevation in um at the
Apollo in New York city so what I told
people that our city hall and all his
staff they took that bit flipped it and
made it things that make you go H and
and I'm I told people that my Foundation
of that material went on to make people
hundreds and hundreds thousands of
dollars and what I mean that is AR Hall
did it but if you Google there was a
group called CNC Music Factory that did
a song that things to make you go
H then crafts and macaroni and cheese
also did a
commercial and they used the cheese as
it was melting and in the background the
song was things that Mickey go home
saying that they macaroni and cheese was
so delicious it would make you go hm all
that came from TK and I just never I
just never tripped about it but I move
different than most people for sure for
sure you're not I mean you're not Petty
I'm not Petty yeah I'm not Petty yo most
of these guys are Petty most of these
guys are Petty and they're ego driven
there's no and they're ego driven I
don't really care about that I I I did
my thing I'm working um and I've always
been this way I've never been Petty and
um I tell people that if someone steals
your
joke actually call that person as a man
and say yo you we you doing my bit and
let me um tell you how it's exactly like
my or I saw you at my show and you saw
me do that which is even worse is even
worse cuz now you're being
disrespectful
um but to actually go on air and say
someone stole my joke because it's not
their set well we've seen people like
really have their careers hit a wall
because of the joke stealing thing yes
but let me let me tell you what I mean
I'm glad you're bringing this up there's
a difference between a set and a joke
okay your set is what you do for 60
minutes right that's your that's your
whole that's your whole no one's
stealing that right someone stole a one
minute joke so if you had 15,000 in the
bank right and someone stole $11,000 at
that 15,000 you're not going to get rid
of the rest of the money right so I
can't tell another comic what he should
be mad about out my purpose of these
interviews that I'm doing is to give
people another way to see
something okay what is a joke and
people's like oh you stole this joke and
they make say you you stole this whole
show but in actual reality you just
stole a joke you didn't steal the set a
joke don't make you your set makes
you why um don't you film your sets for
social media like other comedians are
doing one is because I don't want other
Comics to see it
and two there's Magic on stage with me
there is do you agree I agree there's
magic I agree and I don't want to see it
again because every time is a new
beginning every show that I do is a
different show and if you see one if you
see your set guess what you're going to
try to repeat that again so I take what
I do in track and anything in life when
I ran track and I was good just because
I was good last week don't mean I'm be
good this week so I took that through my
whole life and just because I was funny
when you saw me that don't matter no
more can I be funny tonight but you got
to find different ways to like say when
if you had to be a boxer right right if
you're a boxer you know you could beat
this person but you know what today I'm
tired I can't deliver that same energy
or the audience is different but if you
still find a way to be clever still find
a way to be funny
entertaining yeah work in the crowd
somebody sitting in front you were
clowning on these guys in the front row
these young was hilarious my God it was
hilarious and long as the people walk
out entertained right you were hilarious
so I think the other end of that is or
the other side of that coin is if I saw
you do what you did to those kids yes
that were sitting in the front row that
there was three single young men right
um if I saw that on Tik Tok or or on
Instagram and I didn't know who you were
right I'd be like yo I need to follow
this guy cuz that was great and then I
might be inclined to go see you live
absolutely cuz there are some comedians
who do do crowd work and they show that
but when you go see them they're not
that funny because that's not the same
situation that's going to happen that
night true cuz the crowd's always going
to be different it's always going to be
different cuz like you see like uh have
you heard of Matt re no I haven't so
Matt re uh he's doing like he he's had a
very like insane come up the last 12
months okay so he has he has a Netflix
special but he blew up off of his
crowdwork bits going viral on his
Instagram and on TI and he's a
good-looking young dude okay oh I know
somebody used to manage him okay yeah
just talking about him last time good
looking young guy and but he's very much
new and I mean it's a meteoric kind of
rise in the comedy world I've heard
other comedians talk about it like you
know like it's kind of unparalleled how
fast he's come up cuz he didn't have to
go through the bumps and bruises of you
know performing for 10 people right and
and before you even tell me what happens
I could tell you what how his career is
when you watch him I bet you he's not
that funny well I saw a standable it was
it was it was it was okay it was
mediocre because not that he won't be
funny right he hasn't put the time in
it's the time to be a great comic you
need years of experience you have to
experience life you have to go through
things that's why when you saw Richard
prior he talked about his drugs his
situation what made it funny because he
was living life if you're 20 something
years old you ain't lived right you
talking about sneakers and condoms maybe
and smoking little weed but you haven't
lived and when you have lived and you
have experienced The Experience after
experience keep you more material it's
almost like if you're once you're a
rapper it's like once you hit a certain
level of success it gets harder and
harder to draw inspiration to make music
that is relatable to the people
absolutely because you're older now and
rapping believe it or not is a young
kid's game right it's it's almost like
when Jay-Z did 444 it was like oh [__]
right he made like an album for like a
40-year-old [__] who's like
doing grown man [__] which is hard to do
and it be accepted yep y so true yeah so
that's how that the game is but um it's
good to see from when I started in 1985
it's good to see so many different ways
you can make it in this business like
the gentleman you talking about or for
crowd work yeah um it's also great to
see
that the audience the fans are starting
to tell what is a
gimmick I feel like the gimmicks are
going going away it's about the it's
it's about the jokes yeah it's about the
quality because they're getting tired of
being played that the I saw you on Tik
Tok was hilarious and I come to your
show I spent
$175 $200 and I I didn't get what I
wanted out of your show it's like 50
Cent 50 Cent is go on these world tours
and all these young rappers can't do it
canc they got to cancel tour canceling
it I saw I went to the 50 tour and I was
like you know I've been to shows that
were better I've been to shows that I as
a younger man you know as a younger
hip-hop fan mhm but I don't remember a
show in the last 10 years that I was
more just I just had such a good time
wow cuz I was like gives a great shout
50 is an amazing performer and he's like
we don't we're like like that era we
don't get to see those guys tour right
that's so true anymore right y so it's
like you know to get a 50 Cent tour
where he's doing get rich or die trying
and and and it's just like it just took
me back it was like you know like we
don't get those mega mega mega hip like
you were talking about the Cash Money
Rough Rider story like the days of that
[__] is like people are it's like I feel
like everything feels like a cash grab
yeah I totally agree and that's sad and
even in the comedy world it's a cash
grab people that come to your show like
I don't charge to take pictures after
the show I've seen that yeah and people
will charge you all that money a meet
and greet a meet and greet yeah you you
charge them for a meet and greet that's
a cash grab and it's deeper than that to
me yeah it's deeper than that I'm saying
thank you let me shake your hand and
I'll see you next time I'll see you next
time I want to hold you I want to hug
you because I want you to come back and
I want you to know I appreciate you
spending your hard earned money to come
see me you had to go get a babysitter
you had to tell somebody um you'll be
back in a a few hours you're going to go
see TK Kirkland I understand all that I
don't want to rob you like that you know
I want to charge you for my tickets give
you a great show and have them leave the
same way give memory take a picture
exactly you know so that was it and you
were so genuine cuz you know you can
look someone in their eyes and when you
came out of the show you I just saw it
in your face like you was truly pleased
for sure yeah you know and that's what I
love yeah that was I mean like I said
dude I I like going to the store
sometimes cuz I'll be able to watch like
10 guys right I'll be able to eat wings
have drinks maybe like three of the 10
I'll love you know but to like sit down
and just be like oh [__] this I feel
like I just went to church right yeah I
was uh I I I get on it I get on it and
like I said I dropped the knowledge then
you saw the fun then you saw the
personality then you saw the
appreciation meaning shaking your hands
afterwards saying thank you like a
pastor for sure that's what it was